well joining me now from warwick
university is dr. ben margules who's an
expert in u.s. politics thank you very
much dr. Margolis just how unusual is it
to have demonstrations like this after a
disputed election result and indeed are
these protests really any bigger than
what we've seen in the past well the
only recent historical example I can
think of that would be comparable would
be the election of George W Bush in two
thousand and in that case there were
also a protest at that time his
inauguration attracted large protests
and really so this doesn't really
surprise me it also was a surprising
given the wave of protests that American
cities have been seeing in the last
couple of years mostly relating to
police violence which may also explain
the fairly aggressive police tactics
that you refer to in Oakland but no this
doesn't this strikes me is perfectly
perfectly normal what it also underlines
of course is the different demographics
and different backgrounds of the people
who voted for the president-elect and
for mrs. Clinton well yes I mean the
protests are primarily in urban areas of
course urban areas are more likely to
see protest anyway for geographical
reasons but I mean it the fact that it
does map very well on the urban-rural
divide which this election has excavated
and also of course on the more obvious
racial and I guess you could say values
liberal conservative authoritarian
liberal sort of dimensions devised in
American politics so yes I mean it
certainly highlights the sort of
divisions that this election has made so
visible we're also hearing about quite a
strong backlash in academia on the
campus
of American Universities uh again
there's been a lot of campus protests
around the issues especially of racism
and political what is its opponents
usually called political correctness
that's not surprising there have also
been reports of racist incidents by
people claiming to be Trump supporters
or but people assumed to be motivated by
Trump's victory again that you know that
kind of as a continuation of certain
themes or phenomenon that we've been
seeing on college campuses for a while
now so I mean these the election didn't
produce these divisions they're simply
being activated energized by the fact of
his election and by the fact that
possibly also affect the Trump lost the
popular vote which is even more
disappointing to the Democratic camp
what do you make of Donald Trump's
reaction they're given informally in a
couple of tweets overnight one of them
blaming what he called professional
protestors stood up by the media but
then the other one actually saying more
or less fair enough they're exercising
their right to free speech he's I mean
it's interesting his first tweet is very
much in line with this sort of populist
framing populist theme from the campaign
itself which tended to attack elites the
media being a large part of that elite
and also those groups that trumps voters
found threatening among them protesters
the black lives matter movement was
highly controversial throughout the
campaign so that's expected his second
tweet is interesting you it's not clear
whether he's trying to pitch himself to
a different part of his coalition maybe
the other Republican voters the
wealthier ones who voted for him more at
a party loyalty and expect him to be a
unifier it may be a tactical decision or
conversely he may be torn between his
campaign mode which was fairly you know
with this fairly constant messaging and
the need to be president which is quite
novel and he might be trying to actually
inhabit the role of unifier which yes
stereotypically is what the winning
candidate is supposed to be the whole
speech about you know I'll be president
for all Americans though it was really
surprising to hear from Trump is
actually what most American victorious
American presidential candidates say dr.
Margolis thank you very much indeed for
joining us